19th century london its gas street lamps
thick fog
pollution and claustrophobic streets
inspired histories and legends
the largest urban environment in the
world at the time
london boasted rapid industrialization
significant job opportunities
brutal class division crowded slums
and a fire-breathing wall-leaping
claw-wielding devil
who attacked women in their homes and in
the streets terrorizing a community for
some
67 years introducing one of the world's
first
urban legends his name was springhill
jack
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
early in the 1800s reports of a leaping
man in the form of a ghostly apparition
had already emerged in folklore in
rumors
but the flesh and blood creature took
form in january 1826
when the northampton mercury reported
that a masked man with spring boots
which enable him to vault over a 10 feet
wall was spotted
a man jumping walls in the middle of the
night can easily be dismissed as a prank
right maybe at first but in 1837 his
behavior
and his notoriety changed that year
multiple women gave statements to the
police that they'd been violently
attacked by a monster
who would ring their doorbell or accost
them in the street and then
tear their clothes with his claws since
the victims were working class women
early reports weren't taken as seriously
at first
that is until in january 1838 the lord
mayor of the city of london
sir john cowan read a letter to the
press outside his mansion
the anonymous author claimed they wanted
to bring reports of a supernatural
attacker to the attention of the
authorities
he believed the letters authored to be a
woman who had become
senseless as a result of the strange
attacker and mockingly implored her to
write a description of the demon
that would enable him to catch him now
that the mysterious jack had been
discussed by the mayor
a male authority figure of the upper
class the real attention began
a few days later headlines blamed spring
jack for the attacks
the west kent guardian finally gave the
unknown perpetrator
a title that stuck spring-heeled jack
with the papers giving more pages to the
figure rumors and stories of his attack
spread
wildly and londoners jumped at shadows
convinced springhill jack was coming for
them next
children and adults alike told stories
about him
then in february 20th 1838 miss jane
alsop
the 18 year old daughter of a gentleman
heard a ringing at her gate and there
discovered a man claiming to be a
policeman he announced that they had
captured spring hill jack and she needed
to bring the officer a candle
as jane did so the man threw off his
cloak and applying the lighted candle to
his breast
presented a most hideous and frightful
appearance and vomited
forth a quantity of blue and white flame
from his mouth
and his eyes resembled red balls of fire
he placed her head under one of his arms
and commenced tearing her gown with his
claws
which she believed to be made of
something metallic with great violence
he tore at her neck and arms and even
removed a quantity of hair from her head
one of her sisters heard her screaming
and saw the figure dragging jane down
the stone steps of the house
she barely managed to pull jane back
inside and slam the door
at this time her sister's dress was
nearly torn off
both her combs dragged out of her head
the man continued to knock on the door
until they called loudly for the police
another similar attack by a man of tall
thin and gentlemanly appearance
wearing a cloak appeared in papers a
little over a week later
very quickly springhill jack was labeled
an aristocrat
a report on february 27 1838 in the
morning herald
said that a young servant boy opened the
door to find someone of hideous
appearance
with a claw-like hand and clothing
embroidered with a family crest with the
letter w
a family crest the letter w are first
clues as to the identity of this leaping
legend
an aristocrat maybe someone already
notorious
one man in particular was given credit
for inspiring the first spring heel jack
legends
the marquis of waterford born in april
1811 the young henry de la por beresford
became the third marquis of waterford
following the death of his parents and
older brother educated at eaton college
his penchant for mischief and drinking
earned him a reputation in the press
long before spring healed jack leapt
into the scene reports of the young
marquis smashing windows
offering money to people to fight him
throwing meat out of a butcher shop
and accosting people while naked had
appeared in the press
and he was arrested multiple times for
drunk and disorderly conduct
in one notable incident in april 1837
after our phantom leaper appeared on the
landscape but before
spring healed jack had become a legend
the newspaper the champion says the
marquee and his friends were charged
with starting a riot
and subsequently appeared before the
court wearing bare-skinned coats and
large cravats
reports of the young lords exploits
served as regular fodder for the
newspapers in 1837
the same year we see spring heal jack
described as a devil-like
gentleman as stories of the scandalous
marquis circulated they may have swirled
with the emerging persona of
spring-heeled jack
and it could be in this way the marquee
morphed into a sort of scapegoat
londoners could blame for any evil or
inconvenience
or maybe he was to blame for the crimes
it is certainly possible that the
victims of spring healed jack who
reported being physically assaulted by a
man with claws
were really attacked by human male
assailants but chose to blame the
faceless spring-heeled jack rather than
someone they knew
newspapers at the time at first believed
that attacks to be committed by one
individual
but as reports increased many proposed
it was likely copycats of the original
perpetrator
there were many arrests of men like
charles grenville and james painter
said to be imitating springhill jack
frightening women and children
things turned murderous in 1845 when
maria davis was attacked in daylight it
was reported that springhill jack spit
blue and white flame in her face
then threw her over a bridge into an
open sewer where she drowned
however this account cannot be verified
by any existing records or death
certificates
if this murder never happened then why
suddenly make jack a killer
perhaps the story is meant to further
scare young women about the dangers of
unfamiliar men
springhill jack's character can be
attributed to the genres in which his
stories were published
legitimate newspapers reported his
attacks as hard news
but sensationalized fiction stories
depicted him as an avenger of crime
it was hard for people to tell if he was
a real threat or not
victorian london was a brutal place in
both reality and fiction
people were looking for entertainment
and they seemed to like it best served
with a healthy dose of violence
a play based on spring heel jack called
spring heel jack
premiered on february 26 1838 billed as
a melodrama the creature was brought to
the stage at the royal pavilion theater
which catered to the working class in
1863
a 40-part penny dreadful a type of pulp
fiction story meant to titillate and
shock a generally working-class audience
cast jack as a hero avenging women who
suffered injustice and oppression
the masked version of jack was a tall
form whose head and body glowed
with a blue phosphorescent fire from the
back of which hung
in graceful folds a long striped cloak
multiple times throughout the series the
removal of jack's mask revealed his
identity to the characters in the story
who recognize him
but the name is always cut off midward
as the mark
likely a reference to the marquee quite
possibly the then deceased beresford
newspapers claim springhill jack is a
terrifying boogeyman who scares people
to death
or even outright murders them but in the
penny dreadful series he's a prankster
that functions as a type of robin hood
type figure
for the disenfranchised in one example
he terrifies a girl with his strange and
horrible face with fang-like teeth
and vomit smoke in her face causing her
to faint
only after doing this he writes her a
note saying that he tried to save her
father from being murdered earlier in
the evening
and promises to avenge his death then he
scratches a double cross on her left
shoulder
which is a confusing sequence of events
but hey penny dreadfuls were weird
springhill jack reached such a level of
notoriety that he became the first
victorian urban legend
everyone either claimed to have
encountered him or claimed they knew
someone who had
an urban legend is defined as an
entertaining but usually horrifying
story
based on hearsay that is nevertheless
widely circulated as
true but in reality the majority of
spring heal jack's attacks were likely
false but that's what an urban legend is
all about it's about the friend of a
friend or
my cousin's roommate's boyfriend who had
something bad happen to them
in 19th century london a time and place
of scientific advancement and
technological development
but also abject poverty and income
inequality
springhill jack gave the people
something to hold on to a mystery that
could not be solved by mere
science or even solid police work his
custom footwear constituted a
technological marvel
yet the paranormal components to his
story nodded to age-old superstitions
unlike other monsters of the time spring
hill jack was homegrown
prowling the streets where they lived
not off in some foreign country or
remote location
he was local marvelous fear-inducing
inspiring
springfield jack manifested the fears of
the development of urban spaces
and the upheaval of social classes and
lifestyle changes
city life afforded some scholars argued
that victorian england seemingly
insatiable desire for performative
violence was rooted in the need to keep
people from acting on their real needs
for violence
figures like springhill jack may have
served as an emotional catharsis
perhaps this is also why so many of the
monstrous creatures in this century
appear human or are human frankenstein's
creature
vampires sweeney todd mummies mr hyde
dorian gray the list goes on and of
course there was the very real monster
whose brutal crimes quickly came to
overshadow spring healed jack
jack the ripper this makes me think
about why we've seen spring heel jack
appear
again in popular culture most recently
he's appeared in a comic series a
graphic novel and an award-winning book
part of this comes from the increased
popularity of stories set in highly
stylized victorian settings
like steampunk but part of me wonders if
like the victorians
we too are searching for an outlet for
our own dark desires
finally in this representative
pseudo-historical manned beast whose
story is set in the industrial
revolution
and thus the birth of the modern world
we see another kind of birth
that of the urban legend you're welcome
bloody mary and sewer alligator
sir johan sir john cohen did i say her
say
herstory